ah let's see a lot of people holding
let's try let's try the 704 area code
who's calling from 704 hey David
my name is Alex I'm from Australia
actually I'm staying in Charlotte at the
moment oh alright great teen army what's
going on
ah thank you um I'm just wondering look
part of what my girlfriend's actually
from here in Charlotte and her family
they're big Republicans and I'm I'm
totally against it obviously I haven't
really made that known just as of yet
but my okay Alec so I'm already and you
haven't made it known to your
girlfriend's parents or even to your
girlfriend no no my girlfriend knows her
family doesn't got it because there are
completely like you know Trump
supporters my question would be
basically words are two part of us but
is it even worth me arguing with them
because I believe it's the right thing
to do as you guys are the biggest power
in the world to even confront them on
these sort of issues and basically if I
am to confront them what would be the
best way to convince them that like you
I'll try and bring up the deficit or any
like there's a Trump Russia
investigation they've they're basically
like shrug it off it's beta news what in
your opinion is the biggest issue I
could bring it to the front of them so
basically show them that they're on the
wrong side of history beta at the moment
okay and just so I understand the full
context what what's that what are the
politics of your girlfriend she really
isn't political political at all she
think she comes a bit of an idiot but
she doesn't really go deep into it so
she doesn't know enough she's not really
into it at all interesting so listen I
mean number one if you decide to open
this door understand that you know I
don't know how frequently you're going
to be seeing these these parents of your
girlfriend if very frequently or not
that that might be a factor but you are
putting at risk your relationship with
them by challenging their beliefs that's
number one
I can't counsel you as to whether that's
a good or bad idea you would have to
decide that for yourself I would not
take the approach of trying to quote
convince them as you said on any
particular issue because just like for
example you mentioned the deficit that's
just a political football right they
don't Trump doesn't care about the
deficit Republican
don't care about the deficit and I
assume your girlfriend's parents don't
actually care about the deficit it's a
proxy by which you can criticize or
praise candidates so the approach I
would take again bearing in mind that
you're trying to have a relationship
with these people presumably is I would
ask open-ended questions okay
so when they you you might say something
along the lines of why do you think
Donald Trump hasn't been able to get the
wall built for example and they'll have
some answer of course and then you might
say why do you think Mexico is not
paying for the wall and they're going to
have answers for all of these things but
the ideal optimistic situation would be
that over time these questions rather
than being shrugged off with some kind
of talking point they would actually
start to integrate these questions and
maybe think critically about them and
say wait a second you know that was a
good question he didn't feed me a
different talking point but he got me
thinking and it might slowly evolve
their belief that that's the approach I
would take because it can be you know
you've got to keep in mind that these
are your girlfriend's parents and you
don't want to have I'm guessing a
horrible social situation with them
every time you see each other
of course I think that's actually a
great idea thank you so much all right
and so do you live in the US now you're
just from Australia
I know I live in Australia my
girlfriend's basically gonna move to
Australia but I visit here you know what
you might say you might you might be
able to start dropping hints about how
things are for you too in Australia that
would run counter to their narrative so
for example like I know several
Australian people who have explained we
taxes aren't actually that high like the
idea is taxes are super high because we
get all this stuff from the government
but actually taxes are not that high and
you might start to drop in alternative
ideas about how the world can work based
on how Australia works and your
girlfriend might actually be useful in
that by reporting back to them how
things are going there yeah I think
you're half out on that I've actually
been kind of doing that but
unfortunately Americans when they come
to Australia don't exactly
the the rights you're talking about like
our health care I think it's due to the
fact astray lian's don't have health
care when we come here like they can't
take advantage of our system back home
yes whereas other countries like from
Europe can but which is a shame because
I love all people to take advantage of
our system
I agree well the extent that you can do
that that that would be some some other
advice Alex thank you really appreciate
the call great to hear from you good
luck with that
family situation that is it for calls
for 2018 sorry I couldn't get to
everybody but we are out of time thanks
for being with us many more calls will
be taken next year today's program
sponsored in part by blinkers comm slash
Pakman I've talked about blinkers before
it's this awesome app that I've been
using for several months now and what it
does is take the best and most
critically acclaimed non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks that you can listen to in one
sitting you could listen to ten books in
an afternoon I know that many in our
audience want to expand their horizons
and learn more about all sorts of
different topics but we're mostly
limited by time to some degree I know
I'm not able to read all of the books
that I want simply because I've got
other stuff going on and that's why
blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to be li NK is
t-dot-com
slash PA k ma n